All right. Welcome to
the DDPS seminar everyone.
Before we introduce our invited
speaker, let's go over some
rules and logistics. First of
all, please mute yourself during
the talk unless you have a sense
if you have questions, you're
welcome to unmute yourself and
ask those questions. Otherwise,
please use the chat room to post
your questions so that we can
address them in q&a session at
the end. Second, today's DDPS
seminar is open to external
audiences. Finally, the talk
today will be recorded and
uploaded in our YouTube channel.
That's about it. Now let me
introduce our speaker today. It
is an honor to host Professor
donburi Sue, who is a professor
in the Department of Mathematics
of The Ohio State University. He
received his PhD degree from
division of applied mathematics
of Brown University in 2004. He
conducted postdoctoral studies
in Los Alamos National
Laboratory, Princeton University
and Brown University before
joining the Department of
Mathematics of Purdue University
as an assistant professor in the
fall of 2005. He was promoted to
the rank of Associate Professor
in 2009, and to full professor
in 2012. In 2013, he moved to
the University of Utah as a
professor in the Department of
Mathematics and scientific
computing and the Mises
Institute. In 2016, he moved to
the Ohio State University. He
has received NSF career award in
2007, as well as a number of
teaching hours at Purdue, he has
served on the editorial board of
several journals, including Siam
Journal of scientific computing,
and the Journal of computational
physics. He's the founding
Associate Editor in Chief of the
International Journal for
uncertainty quantification, and
the founding editor in chief of
journal of machine learning for
modeling and computing. His
research focuses on developing
efficient numerical algorithms
for uncertainty quantification,
stochastic computing and machine
learning today, don't Ben will
present an exciting, exciting
topic, which is data driven
modeling of unknown systems with
deep neural network. Please
enjoy and expect a wonderful
talk now without further ado,
let me pass the baton to don't
begin by asking one random
question as usual. Today's
random question is What is your
favorite season from postseason?
Oh,
okay. Well, I guess I don't
really have a strong preference,
but maybe four? Because whether
user is lovely, during the four
nights in a while? Yes, I'm
pretty sure I've been to four.
It's always pleasant, I think.
Right. All right. Stage is
yours. All right. Thank you
Dr. Troy, for the for the kind
introduction. And also for the
for the invite. I'm very happy
to be here today to share some
of our research in the last few
years. As the title says, They
said about data driven modeling
of unknown system with deep
neural networks. So but I would
like to make a point throughout
my talk that the neural network
is deep neural net is a very
powerful tool we use, but what
we are going to present is
fundamentally is a methodology
that, in principle, you can use
some other techniques, but deep
neural net is very, very
powerful. I'm a big fan of
neural network. So let me start
with some motivation. This is
preaching to the choir. This is
something people many of my
friends and colleagues in
national labs are very, very
familiar with. That's that is
how to analyze and predict the
behavior of very, very complex
system like to just borrow a few
slides picture from the web and
also some from my colleagues in
the past this complex system
that is our primary goal for
complex for scientific
computing. And they have gotten
so complex that we need to
incorporate many, many physical
laws or mathematical models. And
most of them have very famous
people's name attached to them,
because they are very well
established mathematical
equations to describe and govern
with very high fidelity of
certain physical phenomena for
example, namely stokes equation
for basically fluid flow right.
And when we deal with very
complex system like that,
climate will be the ultimate
example. And our approach has
always been to let's try to
incorporate as many equations as
possible, as more more physics
as possible as a result, and our
model eventually gets more and
more complex. The point I would
like to emphasize here is what I
would like to call, we have
reached the so called a point of
diminishing return. That is, by
simply Adding more physics and
more equations to the model does
not necessary by us too much.
Yes, we sometimes we see a
little improvement, maybe 10%
effect 10% is a lot, sometimes
we barely see any. And at the
end of the day as model gets at
models become more and more time
consuming. And we end up with
things or this is just random
page output from CNN, one of the
hurricane forecast models. In
fact, there are many, many
models here. And I'm sure, as
you're all aware of each one of
these curves are produced by
highly highly sophisticated,
computationally expensive
models. But at the end of the
day, when we have predictions
like that, what do we do about
them? Is it conceivable even
possible that by adding even
more equations, introduce more
terms in each one of these
model? Maybe some of them will
converge to the physical truths?
To be honest, at this moment,
that answer is not that clear,
right. So that brings us that
short motivation brings us to
the topic of so called data
driven modeling. And the same
message has been made by many
researchers in the past few
years. That is, it has always
been data driven, right. So in
the past effect, especially for
us, especially people in math
department, myself included,
that we tend to think of model
as nice equation, but we
sometimes forget why where are
the equations came from in the
first place, they came from, not
long time, observations
sometimes take decades or even
centuries of observation. And at
some points on smart breeding,
the mind came into play, and
they came up with nice
equations, of course, named
after them. And then we use this
equation, these are the models
we are familiar with, to predict
and analyze the behavior of the
system. Of course, what we have
already accepted that we are not
able to solve all the equations,
these are simple enough. But
most models, mathematical models
we have today are so
complicated. That's why we use
computer. That's the whole
discipline of scientific
computing. And so this would, I
will argue, these days, when we
talk to the model, the real
model is, in fact, a piece of
computer code is a software. And
it's after all are this with
holidays of the mathema, no
matter how beautiful the
equations are, we still need to
deal with them, we need to
approximate them. And maybe
along the way, we even introduce
a bug here and there in our
computer code. But essentially,
at the end of the day, what's
inside the computer is what we
have to rely upon to predict and
analyze the underlying physics.
So the whole idea of data driven
model is that, upon realizing
this path, we can use computer
to help us solve the equation.
And realizing again, our brain
is not sufficient, large enough
to come up with a nice equation.
Why don't we take this all the
way, let's come from data, let's
just use the data to drive
somehow get a piece of software,
and that as a model that we can
execute. And eventually, let's
just use this model to predict
and analyze the underlying
physics. So that's the whole
idea of data driven more than
just to bypass human as much as
possible. So having said all
that, let me be a little bit
more concrete, about what I want
to talk about in this about our
research here, the data driven
modeling. So our focus is both
basically on dynamical system.
So let's assume that I we have
time history of data, this will
call this trajectory of data
over certain time intervals, we
can have many, many of them. And
we don't don't know that the
laws behind the dynamics, we do
not have the governing equation,
if we do have the equation that
by all means go ahead and solve
them. What we want to do is that
using this trajectory data, the
time history, to come up with a
sort of recursive model, that we
can march forward and predict
this will be the model
prediction, the truth evaluate,
evaluate, at the same time, this
is the truth such that our model
prediction is the numerical
model is approximation will be a
very good approximation to the
physical truth. Now, if we have
this model is as if we have the
equation we can discretize it,
and is this without the
equation, but we never will.
We're not we're not really in
most cases can we cannot write
down that mathematical reason.
But we do have this numerical
scheme that can accomplish what
we want to do, which is
prediction of the future. So
here we're talking about
prediction. I want to make a few
very important remarks. Two of
them are very important one is
that and I will emphasize in the
next slides as well, we even
though the time is the data we
have had time in there, we will
by all means do not we do not
want to incorporate the time as
an input variable. And that is
we try not to approximate x as a
function of time. Why the reason
is simple. If we try to
approximate a function as x a
function of time, this will be
our training data or what we see
and yes, we pay Based on this,
we can come up with a nice
medication nice approximation of
x of t. But our goal is
prediction the prediction will
go way beyond whatever we have
observed in our training data.
And so, if our approximate are
coming from this, we will always
be extrapolating beyond what we
observe, no method is reliable
when we extrapolate. So that's
the point I want to make that we
will never try to think of x as
function time as
conversely, here, we only think
of x as a progressive recursive
iteration over time. So time
will now come into play a second
what we observe x may not be the
entire complete set of variables
in the system. So we do not know
the system equation. But to make
matters worse, we may not be
able to observe observe
everything again, climate may be
the ultimate example we can
measure, you know, wind
pressure, pressure temperature,
as a few variables. But the
entire climate system may that
if there is a closed mathematic
model, we may involve, let's say
10,000 variables, we do not have
that we can only measure a
field. So this is a very big
challenge. That's also something
we try to observe, we try to
tackle what if what we observe
the dynamics data is only a
small subset of the entire
system, which we don't have the
equation in the first place. So,
having said that, let me come
back to the part of we do not
want time variable in this. So
this will be an example for the
methodology I will describe in a
moment, we only need short
bursts of trajectory data time
history data. So you can take
the so this will be example of I
say I need eight points along
time history. So you can pull
this out from a single long
measurement data fine, you can
put for multiple pieces here,
you and it doesn't really matter
what it is. So at the end of the
day, we're going to collect them
into a set of measurement of
length eight, let's call this
our training data, and you can
collect the recipe 10,000. Many
of them, if you have long
treasure, the treasure data,
time history, you can throw a
lot of segments out of these
things. So we would prefer them
to be from different
trajectories. But that's
important. And yet mine
secondary concern, the most
important thing that we watch,
next thing we do, we will remove
the time variable, a simple
thing, we just dropped them.
Alright, so by dropping down, we
will not know when exactly this
trajectory occurred in time, as
opposed to goes in here. All we
see are the segments of
trajectory time series of eight
entries. And they are the
AutoCorrect a different time
doesn't really matter to us, all
we carry that we only have each
one of them is as as if they
start with the initial condition
and the mask forward seven times
that all we care. So by doing so
we will remove the time
variable. Also, it makes that
acquisition collection much
easier, you don't need to record
the time, you just need to
record that a relative time. So
that's what we do here. That's,
in fact a very easy thing to
accomplish. Having said that,
let me give the example how this
can come into play. So this will
be very similar to what I just
illustrated earlier. Suppose I
have time history, this will be
example of so called glucose
induced insulin oscillation,
which is, as many of you may be
aware of very relevant to a
diabetes study. Let's assume
that we have measurements of
insulin response after injection
for certain individual, I have
exactly zero to 1516 points, I
do not care about time, there's
only 16 points separated by
times that point oh five certain
unit, I don't do not know
exactly what time they say. But
this is only second point after
initial points. And also I have
this response at certain so
called baseline glucose level is
a single constant parameter.
Every individual have a glucose
level for me sitting here I have
a glucose level yet have a meal,
my glucose level would be
different at different level, if
I go on exercise, this number
will be different is the
constant is an integral
constant. Let's just say we can
collect this kind of data at a
different glucose level. After
injection, the short time
response offense again, zero to
15, only 16 points of this time
time step. Let's say we can
collect many of them. Okay. And
it turns out people can collect
a lot of data about diabetes.
But let's assume this is the
only thing we have. We only have
at the different parameters,
baseline glucose parameter
level, I have the early response
of insulin, we ask the
questions, can we build the
model and understand the very
long time behavior of this
incident? What what happened
after this early stage? So
that's what we're going to do.
So let's try to do a data driven
thing. We don't do not have an
equation for that. So what are
we based on? What do we have,
I'm gonna use a neural network.
And at the input, I'm gonna
throw this single parameter into
one node. And for the
measurement that are from zero
to 15, I'm gonna throw the zero
to 14 to the early nodes. So I
have, this will be 15 plus one
second inputs, I will use a very
last one, as we enforce the
output, that's why we compute
the mean square error to match
the output to the 15th. The last
entry of my measurement data in
between well connect, very
simple, fully connected, feed
forward network. So and then we
have all this data. And you do
it on your own as Trini. I'm
sure many of you are familiar
how this goes to a mini batch
optimization. So this in
TensorFlow, or pytorch. At the
end of the day, once we've
enforced this main square loss
to a certain level, we call this
method Converse. Alright, so
this is what we then we have new
annatto create a model, this
model with the given initial
parameter t zero, given zero to
14 input, I can recursive go
forward in time get 15 then I
can move 15 Here, a slide
everything backward, and I can
get sick thing I can recursively
go forward in time for as long
as I want to. So this will
continue me a long time behavior
of incident, but the difference
that we have now created a data
driven sort of a scalar model
that doesn't require knowledge
of any other variables that are
involved in this as what you can
imagine a very complex math
biology problem. So the question
is that we can always turn that
we'll get the model the question
how good this is. So let's do
some validation and plot a few
others initial structure zero to
15. same setting as before, at a
different glucose level is one
and we're gonna feed them into
the network neural network model
we just created is the one model
we created we'll never touch it
again we only execute on the
different certain days. So,
let's feed this initial one a
correspond to T 010 Put this
into initial condition, Mars is
for entire form much longer time
this was the result we get
everything of the circle the
circle would be what we feed
into the network everything
afterwards would be the
prediction by network itself. As
you can see the network
prediction will be the blue very
close to the truth I will tell
you in a moment what truth is,
you can see the agreement is
quite well and is reached steady
state which is obviously not
very obvious from what we can
observe from the initial
evolution right this goes to set
the state take another current
1.1 And the system again after
initial condition the predicted
by the network itself go again
goes to steady state with some
observation earlier pick another
curve and yes again steady state
and then also the US citizen
become a little more obvious at
early stage another curve 1.3
All the sudden the neuronode
process is a periodic state
which is much the troops and
again everything of a circle is
pure prediction no data anymore
and make a different G zero
level these become even bigger
oscillations alright. So and you
can see the math with the so
called truce here is very very
close. And now that we have this
scalar model for single variable
incident for his longtime
dynamic we can analyze that and
now we see this accurate enough
I can play god mode, we can just
simply interrogate this model
get all kinds of behavior out of
it one thing people study in
this phenomena is that people
already know that G zero is the
single parameter please plays a
key role in determining the long
term behavior of system so in
here is a steady state and here
is the periodic states. So, what
we people do is that they just
record the max and mean of the
when the system reached a stable
state. Now here maximum would be
a same number here maximum will
be above here means here and you
plot this max the mean against
the single parameter you get
this kind of bifurcation
diagram, when G zero is quite
small, we have a steady state
max and the match each other and
when t zeros past certain
threshold, it become a periodic
state and the amplitudes become
bigger and bigger and bigger and
all of a sudden passing here the
system return to the steady
state again. So it's quite
interesting behavior. Once again
this up blue curve blue dots are
produced by just interrogating
this neural network model and
the reality the truth okay. So,
we can also do things like with
different GCL single parameter
and the system will respond with
different than if I have a meal
my G zero will be at a different
level, the response will would
be different if have another
dessert and much easier, cast
higher and high. Anyway, this is
this This can result people
invested in the literature. So
having a Once again, you can see
here the neural net model has
very remarkable accuracy
compared to the truth. And what
is the truth here, we don't
really have real data, the truth
in our case, is produced by
synthetic data coming from this.
So the whole thing is about
incident response is in some
very complex math biology
system, I wish I had no idea
about what we did. There are
several models to study this
incident response. So we pull
this one from one well
established textbook is
reasonably complex with this
bifurcation behavior. These are
the two models we use, and has
four state variables, and about
16 parameters. We put all the
parameters around the book,
everything you standard from
textbook, what we did we solve
this system with these
parameters with MATLAB with
accuracy. But we record for
network purpose, we record only
two things, why is z z, this g
zero the single parameter in our
modeling. The other one is the
early response of I, zero to 15,
the first second entries of the
response, everything else from
the model, we throw them away,
they are never recorded, as if
we don't know. So this is just
pretend. In the real world, we
can only measure this and the
early response of this. Based on
this little thing you can see
the neuronal can build the model
that analyze a long time behave
of AI without any knowledge of
any other variables whatsoever.
Okay, the reintroduction
everything, you'd basically as
if I have no idea how there's
physics involved, what's
variable involved, I just What
do I see and what we model
that's so, I hope by this by
this example, at least is so so
that the you know, you suggest
that it is possible now that we
can build very accurate the
model and closed by itself. And
this closed method system
closed, this closed system,
right, everything defined each
other, but self closed for only
a subset of variable, which in
this case, there is not a single
mathematical model to government
evolution by we have to rely on
other variables. For the data
driven modeling. It doesn't
require that. So having said
that, like I said, when we have
this data, we throw them into a
network is not a random choice
we made. In fact, this work was
a result of several about four
or five years development over
the over this year when in fact,
the example is in none of these
papers. When we try the example,
we actually no there is no way
it does not wait has to work, it
turns out to be a one of the
easiest example to train and to
get high accuracy. So so this is
what I want to talk to you about
the so called method, so called
Flow Map learning, I just call
this F ml, and how it works. And
how it makes gets us to the
modeling of the software only a
single variable in a much, much
bigger system. So again, this is
setting. So just 10 seconds of
neural network, we do not
require any special uses of any
special structure of neural
network, all we use that neural
network does, at the end of the
day is a mapping from input to
output. In this case, we input
the map to H R H to four
variables R four. And in between
more almost all our works, we
simply use fully connected feed
forward network with nothing
special user usual ReLU
activation function. And
sometimes we use tan h, we
didn't use any of these nets
turns out there's no need for
any other special network. So
let me come back to
the basic setting. So now, let's
let me start with a simpler
system. Simple problem. That is
I have a dynamic system that we
do not know, the governing
equation, right, so but we do
have observation of x. So we
observe every variable in the
system. So this will be the
evolution of x. And again, from
that time history will prove us
trajectory out of this. That's
our training data. It's a very,
very busy field of so called
data driven equation recovery.
That is where the measurement
time has of x let's try to
recover. If we do not do that,
in fact, we have equals, we have
some early work on that as well.
In this work we do and try to
recover f at the point being
that you want to recover F with
some error. I mean as loss most
likely is nonlinear, we still
need to discretize it and make
it into a computer code
algorithm. So here let's not try
to do that. Let's again like I
said let's do the one shot we
want create a model directory in
one step. So we try to
approximate the underlying flow
map. That's why where the name
came from for the method, what
is flow map flow map is simple
concept in dynamical system is
simply the mapping between
solutions at one stage t zero
can be any time to another state
t. So this is the mapping with
parameters I would like to see
something something admin right
to ensue, need admin rights, I
just click as x as anyway,
hopefully I don't talk anyway.
So the mapping is just an empty
map solution from one time to
another time for autonomous
system like this, only time
difference matters, that's key
things with time doesn't really
matter. So let's to look at any
is any solution from data from
one instance to the next. And
they're all separate, let's
assume the timestamp is constant
delta delta t. So the mapping,
this promo is simply x map to
the current time to the next
stage. Right. So that's governed
by exactly same map covers by
the same parameter, which if we
assume constant, this doesn't
even matter here. So this is
simply map from RT to RT. And
that's what we can do with any
mapping. So in this case, we
only need the two data from any
trajectory. So a you can pull a
pair consecutive pair anywhere
from time page to pull them out.
Alright, so then I will just
call these the first 1x. One,
the second one is x to the all
relative, again, time doesn't
matter is only relevant relative
position, everywhere case, x
1x 2x. When its current state
solution, x two is the next one
step later. And this is branch
wide by this map, which are the
two are the the concept becomes,
we want fun rd to rd, let's try
to minimize this error. So I
will find a map approximate
approximate amount to this such
that my output by my mapping
would try to match the real
thing. As much as possible mean
square loss, you minimize this
problem is risk like everything
like the non easterly LeaseWeb
problem, there's nothing fancy
to that, once we find this
mapping, and you can now execute
given any x one, you can keep
recursing of going forward in
time. And that will give you
predicts for a long, long time
is the d dimensional function.
approximator is not operator
learning. That's a key thing.
Why because you only care about
the function from rd to R, the
output D doesn't really matter.
But as I said, it's not operator
learning, which is a busy topic
these days is simply because
again, the fact that I said we
did not ever ever try to write x
as fans of TF have little T
inside and become an operator.
But now we only look x as a
vector. So it's multi
dimensional coordinate is a
function approximation for low
dimensional can to polynomial
Gaussian process everything. In
fact, if it is reasonable or
small, I will just say by all
means go with potty mouth, it
kills the problem with
extraordinary high accuracy.
That's our words, in fact, our
first paper on this, but most
likely, in practice, it is not
very small. So new anatomy is
essential, very, very powerful.
So this is how it works. Again,
we are if you insist, we also
advocates use neural network.
And then of course, the network
output, which is minimize this
error. This is very simple,
fully connected, feed forward,
this will be our friend. And you
can also do RESNA, which in our
first paper we advocate of doing
that the retina is simply says
this mapping, it just doesn't
try to map from input to output.
In fact, this part is mapped to
the difference. And as a result,
we took prediction, you have to
add this back on you can then
that will be the scheme that's
the only difference between
these two, they are absolutely
equivalent, mathematically,
there's no difference is plus
minus one, depending on where
you put them.
But this ResNet structure looks
like all of our stepping, except
it is not auto forward. That in
fact, the entire error here has
nothing to do with delta t so
this exact integral in time,
there's no temporal error, no
explicit dependency on delta t
the other errors basically meet
the minimization of the training
error. So, in our early work, we
had used ResNet primarily to
wish I found this
computationally advantageous,
but as we gain more and more
experience, we have found that
that you know, this thing will
requires very high accuracy at
the end of the day, whereas that
doesn't really matter. So you
use your choice whether you use
them use it or not. We still
keep residents in most of our
work is just mostly for from the
legacy code. Alright, so let me
show you one example. Again,
this example has is a four
dimensional example. So my
status variable u one u two, V
one v two to sort of OD, two
algebraic constraint, there's
not really od right. So, the
mapping as I said will be art
for to our four is reasonably
low dimension. Let's do in fact
this result is produced by
polynomial it will not work a
similar result. Alright, so, and
this the producer of the 1000
steps. Again, the training data
is just one separated by one
step you see extraordinary short
time phase which is one step
right And I want to make a
again, an effort is that upon
you that you look at this
function, the V tool response,
and v one as well, as a function
of time, this extraordinary
difficult function to
approximate with a spikes like
this, there's always no method
that can really approximate
these kinds of spikes with high
accuracy theory, it is very
accurate. Why? Because once
again, as I said at the very
beginning, we never try to
approximate x as a function of
time, we only try to approximate
X, how it evolved over one step
as a function, right? So once
you get every one step correct,
it is eventually will produce
the correct function over time.
This is exactly how anytime
integrator Max works. If you
knew the equation, you can solve
this by rune Dakota known score
that looks exactly like that,
except n is well defined from
the equation, you know what this
is here, we just don't know what
the end is, we use data to try
to learn this. But the time
server allows us to go
progressively in time,
accurately every step, and
eventually it can produce some
vastly compressed behavior over
time. But the function this
thing as function of time never
come into play. So that's the,
again, the message I think I'm
overstating a little bit. But
again, this is the key feature
of this method. Alright. So now
let's move on to the very
practical situation, that in
most cases, we cannot measure
every variables in the entire
system. So now, let's have the
whatever come autonomous system,
there's a big complexity that we
don't know the equation, we have
no idea what the f is. So when
in fact, we probably don't even
have idea how many axes
variables, we need to have this
just, we have no idea. But we do
have is that we can measure a
few a subset of them. So Z, like
I said, in the climate modeling,
this can be temperature can be
pressure can be dense, then stay
on a few things. And everything
else who are the missing
variables, we may not even know
how many were missing. Is it
550 5000 10,000? Missing? We
have no idea because we don't
know what the complete system
look like. But we have let's say
you you measure three variables?
That's all we have the question
we ask based on time, which of
these three variables? Can we
build a model for these three
variables only, in principle,
coming from autonomous system,
is it possible there's a so
called very well known mores
wanting the formula says, you
know, this kind of equation does
exist, in principle is not
useful, because you start the
equation look like this, this is
my COVID term, this some
integral term. And that's
initial condition, we don't know
usually treat it as a random
variable. So this is not
important. What's not useful is
that this formula is exact
formula, but it's only sort of
like existence, it doesn't tell
us how to get our how to get in
most important is k, the kernel
thing. And so there has been a
lot work on estimating
approximating kernel k from
here, but that's based on the
knowledge we know the letter F
in the first place, we are
trying to get to K. But here, we
do not know this anyway, so
there's no way we can have cake.
But nonetheless, we're going to
use this as a motivation to
design our data driven approach.
Alright, so the motivation goes
goes like this, you look at this
integral. So if we want to know
any the evolution of the the
observables, that count the
time, let's call this T, this
needs to go back from as far as
equals zero with Tina minus that
it will be content T, S goes to
t, this T month you will be
zero. So this requires us to
know the solution at the current
time, go all the way back to the
initial condition, we're going
to make a very mild assumption
that he has these so called a
memory memory that can go very
long in most system, so we only
need to go back from the current
time to some fixed time.
Alright, so you do not need to
know your solution today or
tomorrow. You do not need to
know everything has happened
through the beginning of the
universe, in fact, in most cases
will go back to a certain amount
of time, that's enough. Anything
further back in in history, do
not have any impact on the
current state. That's the final
memory assumption, which is
almost universally true for any
system. And of course, the
difference is that the key that
How long should we go back? And
we don't know. But that's
problem dependent. But let's
assume we can, we should only go
back from here, back towards
final time. That's how we go.
Alright, so now this integral is
replaced by this with some
negligible error. That's the
first mild assumptions. Now that
we change this to a final
integral that doesn't depends on
t anymore. We're just gonna
assume before final integral, we
can we have some kind of
approximation method that can
compute this number very
accurately based on small
thresholds based on whatever
data in between these two in
between count the time to
backtrack, the memory time. This
again is easy, because if we
know the equation, we can simply
do some kind of gross
quadrature. This will be this
exists here, of course, we do
not know the integral part, we
always say, you know what a good
approximation exists, that's all
we need. Alright, having said
both now we say we exchange this
to approximate formulations that
if we let's call the current
time t, n, if we want to know
that you've always had current
on tn, we just need to know this
a TN and this entire Indigo
depends on everything to
backtrack one step two step,
whatever number of steps that
content in the memory. That's
how we do. So this is our
approach discrete approximation
to the mores once the equation
based on very mild assumption,
and this just tells us, we just
need to find this and this, but
we don't have this. That's what
we do with data driven, we just
said, our model says, in order
to know one step in the future,
all we need is the current time
step and something go back in
time, we need data on this. And
we'll see if we can create this
mapping, that's the model. So
the function approximation
become that given this metadata,
so this will be n plus one times
d, that data to this mapping,
this will be our mapping, we
want to fund this. And this will
be the network structure if we
want to do so find this
operator. And this will be
example says I only need to go
back to step in memory, this is
the current, this is the future,
if we go with one and two. And
if you have data, if you have
enough data of three map to one,
you have data lands, at least
four in your time history, you
can create input and output. And
you can have many of these you
turn network that will be the
model. And the model is in fact,
coming from very rigorous
derivation. So as I said, here,
this is relationship here has
nothing to do with neural
networks, neural network is just
a way to try to create this
operator. And so anyway, so this
will be the example I showed you
earlier, like the instant
example goes from zero to 14,
and with a one parameter here,
and to the next. Right, so. So
that neural network model of the
training doesn't doesn't really
give us more research on these
methods, eventually, it doesn't
give it just give us a direct
predictive model that we can go
forward in time. How does this
compare to the more is the one
that we don't know, in fact, as
we're not even trying to recover
more is wanting in this case. So
let me show an example a linear
system equations. Linear squares
turns out to be quite difficult
to model. It's x dot equals a x,
let's say I have 20 vector of
20. A is a 20 by 20 matrix, we
come up with some random choice
of these A, we can solve them.
With our synthetic data, we
assume we don't know anything
about 10 component, we have
short time measurement countries
are the first 10 component of x,
we know nothing about the 400
parameter in this system, we
know nothing about the missing
10 variables. And in fact that
now you can see that the 10
variables here, do not give us a
closed system to solve always
requires not as a cue. Alright,
so I will contest in this case,
how long is the memory, when we
create a memory when you plan to
six, let's call this second. So
it's very short trajectory we
need we just need to see many,
many pieces of this we create a
mapping and then we were going
to execute for the prediction of
x one to 10 forward in time to
go all the way from zero to 150.
A very long time prediction,
this will be the x three this
will be the x six. Alright, so
as you can see the neural net
model, which is rare compared to
the truth by solving the entire
system, and is very, very close
after this long time in a non
tuba dynamic. So it's not steady
state is not purely to Radek
state is unclear what state is,
but anyway, the accuracy is
good. Let's make this slightly
slightly nonlinear. So let's
deal with not very chaotic but
not very chaotic. It's a fast
slow variable. So the x 123 Are
the slow variables. And why the
fast well how fast is it depends
on how small epsilon is. We
assume that we can measure
slower but in most cases, that's
where you can fast variable too
fast, we cannot measure. So
based on that complex data x
123. We want to create a model
for the slow variables only. So
this is like coarse graining
homogenization you name it that
we always try to come up with an
effective model for the slow
variables, the course variables.
In this particular case, we're
going to homogenize this
mathematical formalization. Just
get rid of this and that's the
mathematical model, which is
exactly when epsilon go to zero,
right. So you Here, let's fix
the case apps X absolutely is
point one. So it's not exactly
this not very accurate, but it's
reasonably good. At the same
time, we can use measurement
data 123, left neural network
create a model for x 123. You
know how much the model, and
this will be the prediction
accuracy, this prediction of x
one, from zero to 200 to 400, I
did not plot the first 200,
because if I do that, everything
cluttered looks like random
noise. But upon cloud zoo, if we
zoom in, they're not random
noise that determines chaotic
system. So the first 200 is
probably the entire is missing,
the memory is 1.2. That's the
math 20 Do we have, we just need
the data of x 123 of lens 1.2.
This prediction up to 400, you
can see neural network is a read
the Choose computing from the
real system. And synthetic data
is the black you can see the red
and black check each other
really, really, really, really
well. And the blue, which is a
human created,
homogeneous system, you know,
human approximate is not too
bad. But you can visually
visually see the difference
compared to the truth. If we
compute the error over lambda,
this will be the error by our
human model human created model.
So that now is from zero to 400.
These are typical error behavior
girls over time, nothing
surprising this error by the
machine learning close model by
neural network, the error is a
lot smaller and a lot more
stable, we do not have a full
understanding of the runtime
stability behavior of these
neural net models, just because
we don't have enough
mathematical tools to understand
your network. But we have seen
this kind of behavior very, very
often it's the longtime behavior
stability can often be
surprised, surprising, but in a
very pleasant way. So let's make
this fully chaotic. So it's nice
as much smaller system. Let's
look at Lauren 63. So this will
be the exact Lauren system
through which we generate
synthetic data and validation
data. And we tried to model only
x that we only have x as a data,
we create a scalar model for x.
But here I will show you x and y
because x and y I can plot in a
two dimensional plot. So let's
pretend here we have recorded
time series of x and y only, but
we know nothing about Z. Right?
So this so based on x and y,
we're gonna use neural net to
this flow map learning to create
a model for x and y only. And is
we need a history, the history
is point one times that point o
one. So this requires to have 10
step of measurement data x and
y, this will be the school
dimensional the deep neural
network model the face portrait,
it starts from here, this is up
to 100. In fact, I think it is
more than 100 Maybe 1000. I
forgot. But anyways, long time
integrins was and this will be
the exact model. But the Phase
project would project on
excellent why the truce, you can
see visually This is very good.
We don't have good point wise
error is chaotic system, nothing
would track the Pontoise error
accurately over on time, it's
just nature of chaotic system.
So here we just look visually,
they look qualitative,
qualitatively, they're close
enough. We also based on this
data, we computed a few measure
for the how chaotic the system
is the so called correlation
dimension, approximate entropy
layout, no exponent is a number
from the neural network model
these are choose, you can see
that the number of reasonably
close I mean, they're not super,
super close, but they're
reasonable. Turns out these
numbers very hard to get stable
number this really depends on
how many entries you have in
the, in the in your time history
is very sensitive to that. So
but anyway, we think this these
are very, very reasonably good
match. Let's make the system
bigger, this low res 96, which
has 40x, or x goes state
variable has x 240. We only
record x 123. And we use neural
network to record to produce a
three dimensional model. The
history again is point one. So
when you're 10 Step pong with
hands up ping pong oh one. This
is a three dimensional Phase
project up to 500 very long time
the integration. And this is the
40 dimensional model project in
three dimension. This is now it
gets messier is unclear what
this looks like. But anyway,
this looks reasonable. And then
we compute this chaotic measure,
they all look reasonable close
some numbers very closer. And
the invariant measure that
distribution that's upon steady
state. Again, they look fairly
reasonable across right. So this
is chaotic. So let me give you a
short summary. What we did here
that when we don't have a
dynamical system, that's okay is
it first if we can measure we
have time because of all the
variables is a simple case, you
just create a one step mapping.
Your training data is only one
Two steps. And you can get her
out of it, even though in most
nuanced funny when you're
10,000 20,000 History trends,
but this 10,001 is out of one
step that so the overall data
requirement is in fact very low
thinking about the up to one
system prediction sometimes
services and you can easily go 1
million steps that you can pull
off a two step data from here.
This is what it looked like. If,
however, what's your data is
only a partial measurement, then
that requires memory, and then
this will be the mapping, and
you have more terms on the left,
alright, in both cases, we
advocate the use of neural
network because the dimension
would be high. Keep in mind
here, for example, here with two
step memories, three dimension,
but each z is a vector, if z is
a vector of 10, this is 30
dimension. So dimension goes
high very fast. So and as I show
you several examples, it looks
really, really well, we just
make a quick remark that you can
also model system with different
controls. And all excitations,
the key of this, there are some
modifications had to go into
there. But at the end of the
day, you can do, you can train
your neural network model based
on some control, then the
prediction that come to can be
entirely different that's never
ever present in alternative
data. So this is a very
remarkable property, we have
found this from this thing, by
looking at one step at a time
never have time involved, that
allows us to do that. So this
paper has a detail on that. So I
don't have time on this, I want
to give you a note, just a few
minutes, a quick idea on how we
do this with PDE. Because we
have discussed so much about
dynamic system. PDE is what
people really care about. So now
it's a similar setting. Suppose
I have a set of grid on which I
have data. So the data is my ID,
now it's a field. So they say I
can think of my observation as
one vector field as if this is a
finite element solver, your
grid, your grid will be a vector
of length, let's say 10,000. If
you have 10,000, know that you
have an atom solver. So it's a
one big vector. Suppose the
autonomous suppose we observe
every view, and now it's fully
observed system, it's just like
od upon this with holidays, oh,
the PDS OD. And is, nothing is
missing. So we just need to map
from current state to one step
later you have this, we can
create a map, we can solve this,
learn this unknown PDE. Right?
Players, it doesn't really work.
We try this many, many times, no
less than 1000 different cases,
it just didn't work. Why is
because in dynamic system, the
mapping between this other state
variable x, x such as vectors,
they're components of vector.
Nothing we can say about this,
the dynamic system for PD is
different, they use our solution
in space, they are not random
components of a vector u has
smoothness and regularity, they
are connected in through them,
because PD has operator in them.
So there's a smoothness
regularity in there that we are
not enforcing here does know
things. When I say they don't
work, they don't really not
work, they just work sort of
inconsistently. And without the
high accuracy of Sony without
this work, we really demand
accuracy to be high. So we
eventually filed convolution
network still didn't quite work.
Again, no less than a few 1000
test cases still didn't quite
work. So we eventually were
forced to develop for the first
time. And that was structure to
enforce something. Again, it was
it is motivated by the
mathematics. So suppose I have a
PDE like this involves some kind
of differential operator, I
don't know what they are, I
don't know what else is I don't
how many, but I suppose I know
the PDE. And suppose I have a
set of grid. And I can solve it
by some kind of order for I'm
not going to do that. But all of
our does exist, right. So once
that mapping from here, this
will be my operator, and each
derivative would be replaced by
some differentiation matrix that
numerical analysis helps. That
is everything linear matrix
vector product for derivatives,
this would be my very naive old
iPhone, it stability would most
likely be an issue but we're not
solving we just need this to be
on a conceptual, conceptual
level, it exists, it gives me a
some kind of truncation error,
one step. And we'll just say
that since we don't know this,
we don't know the derivative, I
would just say, you know, what
we can make every differentiate
some matrix, a nonlinear vector,
the operator, it doesn't even
need to be linear operators, if
I make everything linear
nonlinear is incorporate this as
a special case. So so the
existence all of our cells that
exist even bigger class and
nonlinear scheme, such that my
error once Deborah could be at
least could be smaller, it at
worst will be like this. So it's
a special thing. Just we're just
making this class of method.
Start now neither all of a much
bigger much broader and we are
saying that the arrow will
commit or One Step most likely
will be smaller than this, but
at worst case will be just like
this. Why? Because I can simply
put these back into my linear
matrix. that exists. So that's
all we need. So, these are when
we say this nonlinear or forward
method does exist like this with
some of the we don't know, and
this this operator correspond to
L. This is how we design our
neural network structure, the
input, once that input the
vector, our fan atom in the grid
is here, the output is here, in
between we have a certain neural
network in power goes for it
this way, in parallel in this
direction, each one corresponds
some can nonlinear operate with
that we do not know. And then I
have another network, horizontal
here acting component wise
against all of them. This is no
need operator here to learn the
L here. And if we connect these
together, that I can train, and
this one works consistently. In
fact, without this layer, what
we call assembly layer up to
here these days is resembles
convolutional very much.
Alright, so this is the key.
This is what we call the
Decembrie block. The assembler
layer is what really makes
everything worse to enforce
regularity and things like that.
Let me quickly show you a few
examples. Again, the equation
here only serve the purpose of
generating training data and
validation data. So the equation
may be simple. UT plus u x
equals zero, the simplest
equation analytically, perhaps
the most difficult one to solve
accurately numerically, again,
everything here just read out
one step vector. Here, we have
50 nos, you will be the vector
of 50 to 50 mapping. So there's
nothing missing just one step
mapping in between how that
assembly assembly block. And
this will be, you know,
predicted over a fairly long
time that 20 to one, you can see
the accuracy quite well. In
fact, the dispersion error is
much much better than we
expected many numerical method
if you know, we know the
equation to solve this by some
standard numerical method as to
what it was so worth this
personnel. But he or he just by
learning, then equation isn't
the ration diffusion doesn't
really matter. I'll just want to
show you that it works with now
uniform grid in this case that
the grid is not only non
uniform, they also randomly
permute it within this matter
doesn't require any knowledge of
the physical structure of the
grid, that geometric structure
connection is not required, you
can deal with higher density or
this easier case, because in
more diffusive diffuse
equations, I'll be easy to
simulate integral equation which
if I can make the effective make
this non local problem again, is
diffusive. So it's very easy
accuracy is good. For this
equation, you will be an
interesting example, that again,
in this case, when we generate
the training sample, we have 50
nodes, we solve this by some we
actually don't, at the
beginning, we only we solve this
analytically, that means that
our our training, data is
created by some random like
Fourier series sine cosine, we
created their their finest
theory so that they are very
smooth, we solve this by one
cons that we support a 102
Nothing happened or one times a
no shocks whatsoever. So that's
our 20 that also need a small
sine, cosine, or one steps,
which is also similar sine
cosine. Upon learning the
operator mapping between the two
steps, if you execute this on
the new initial condition over a
much longer time, when it will
appear, it does appear. So
that's the thing I would like to
emphasize here again, is we do
not need to see the physics in
order to predict the phasing
into in a very, if you recall,
in the very first instant
example this already showed up.
Now one of the early stage, the
incident response has studied
the periodic state, you'll never
see that internal data. But over
long term, if you have the
correct model, you will produce
the correct physics and the
physics is always a very short
time dynamic, it doesn't have
any interesting fits in the
short term, you all ones up
almost nothing happens. To make
matters a little more
interesting here, we assume that
we can only observe grid value
add right half in fact 40% of
the domain and in this case, we
actually do need to use memory
because these are 50 vector or
50 or we only observe 20 of
them. So a missing 30 component
is missing variable we have
memory, but with sufficient
memory, you can still predict
fizzy in here and this accuracy
isn't that high, but we say You
know what, in this case with
shock and 40% domain you know, I
will give this a pass. So, let
me just finish continue to
dimension and unstructured grid,
there will be two dimension but
this PD but the entire is one
set of variable completely wiped
out we only have data v this
very expensive, this is like 50
by 50 grid. So the vector will
be 2500 length. With memory I
believe we have 10 memory. So
this will be 25,000 input for
neural network. So it's a little
bit expensive, but long term
prediction the solution go is up
down sort of sort of periodic
with a little bit diffusion. And
you can see the reference
prediction looks fairly
reasonable. So anyway, let me
finish time is up. What I've
discovered what I call the F L,
the flow Macron is a method, or
it's a methodology, again, I
want to emphasize is not, it
shows some capability that was
never really, we didn't really
thought about before. For
example, if we can model only
things we observe, so this will
be very useful, if we try to do
some kind of multiscale modeling
or try to speed up competition
by only predicting the cost
variables, we suppose faster, or
you just planned this, I only
see this a model is right. So
without worrying about any other
variables that may or may not
coupled with the things we want
model. But this capability is
new in certain way. Like I hope
this talk has illustrate for you
that it's not because they knew
and that is simply because we
set up the problem
mathematically correctly. And we
set it up as correct mapping
from input output neuron that is
a very powerful to one, which
I've a big fan fan of, but it's
not what brings the magic, the
magic is about setting it up
properly. And in most cases, our
network is very small. It's not
really deep learning like this
is not very deep. But anyway,
there's no really need to use
special structure. The thing was
memory, a one they asked some of
you may ask, can you famous
network structure that
incorporate memories? LSTM? Can
you do that? Yes, if you are
missing variable, if you do
LSDM, you can accomplish about
the same result. We have our
collaborator who has tested this
software extensively. But then
the is back of the question. In
our case, if we know how it
works, why do you need to
introduce this structure with a
gate and everything? You know,
it's a small plane network with
Candida. So anyway, one big
thing I would emphasize is that,
and for many of you who have
done your last funding, who
really high on the accuracy of
things, you know how hard it is
to reproduce. The result is for
students who are trained that
when you try now, today,
tomorrow, you may or may not be
the same, you'll put a code from
GitHub from somebody paper, and
you will try to replicate the
result you cannot, whose fault
it is. So in our group,
reproduce, the reproducibility
is the number one criteria, good
results or bad results better be
reproducible. So almost, we're
in the process of organizing
almost all the example I
discussed here in this talk and
many of our papers, to put them
online, including the training
that how to generate a synthetic
training training data set. In
fact, the training data set we
used to just generate example,
more importantly, we're going to
put the data we used to plot the
plots, so that you can reproduce
what we had in paper immediately
and then compare to your
results. So
I'm also in the process of
writing a very detailed paper
describing the computational
details, the arts, how to create
reproducible plots. So anyway,
all of this will be available is
in the process of getting
uploaded at the moment, I have a
new website that I use in the
making. But anyway, this will
come up in just a few weeks. So
with this, I will finish and
take some questions.
Thank you. Thank you so much.
Thanks again, for the wonderful
talk. I enjoyed it a lot. I'm
sure everyone else enjoyed it a
lot as well. Although it's 11.
How, let's have a q&a session.
Don't be I hope you have some
time.
I do have some time. So I don't
know how to see chat.
Yeah, well, don't worry about
it. Okay. So, Pat, are you
there? Or are you still there?
Um, you posted a lot of
questions. And
and yeah, just let let me let's
just take the most important
ones. Yeah. There are other
questions to that from other
people. So. So you seem to be
assuming that, that neural nets
are the way to go here rather
than trying to discover the
equations themselves in some
interval form. And there has
been a lot of work for decades
on that approach. So could you?
I mean, of course, there's also
been a lot of recent work on on
using neural nets to do similar
kinds of things, because could
you just talk about the pros and
cons, and why you think that
this is doesn't have to be
better? Right? This could be
just one among many approaches.
But you did suggest at times
that you thought this would be
better than other approaches,
including implicitly better than
learning the equations directly.
What's your opinion on this?
So yeah, so I do. I didn't say
that. Your neck was very
powerful. Again, like I said in
this but you don't have to do it
on network. So you want that in,
in all these things we did here.
It's just a tool to to
accomplish this kind of mapping
so it just a way to accomplish
It's mapping. Like I said, if
the dimension is low for novel
cures, polymer is the king. But
I am a fan of neural network
because many of cases the
dimensions very high the input
the nodes. And so let's do new.
And so I,
why do you believe that neural
nets will be better than say,
trying to discover the, the
equations in classic od form.
So that's a that's had nothing
to do so again, is I want to be
very clear, is I will advocate
in getting this off model neuron
that can be part of our
community, as opposed of
discount F in it. So we have
done similar things. So let's
say you want discover F. So
let's just assume you can
discover F analytically Correct.
All right now.
I'm talking about inducing it
from the data in the same way
you are with a neural net. Yes,
that's why I'm saying that if
you can induce F from data,
first of all, you can never
induce F, exactly correct. You
have error in the first place,
right? Then you have the D
squared as whatever the
approximate f to start with, you
induce another error. So error
compound on itself, you're
solving the wrong, you're
solving sort of slightly the
wrong equation in the first
place.
So just to be clear, are you
saying that, forget about
whether you do in neural nets, I
it sounded as though you rather
than learning a differential
equation where a difference
equation, whether it's in neural
net or other form, that you're
learning, mapping directly from
those values at one time step to
the next time step, you're not
learning the difference? You're
learning.
My point is, regardless where
you're where you come from, you
can try to use your data to
recover F to the other form. At
the end of the day, your
prediction look like this. One
step to the next is a mapping.
So that's what we just tried to
go to this one start mapping in
one shot, because I believe
one shot there because it's
overloaded. It's
nice, I have data, I want to
create this one step mapping in
one step, that's all. And as
opposed to separate the tasks,
you will introduce error in
different stages, they compound
on each other make their way,
days and plus Y equals X some
kind of
execute, we should follow up
separately. I've got I got your
email address. Someone else had
a question about noise?
Noise. Very good question noise.
There are two kinds of noise.
Why is the standard measurement
or if folks in this slide, if I
have x 1x, two, both have
observation noise, this is
easier to deal with in the sense
that you just steal because at
the end of the day, the learning
part of the things I discussed
here is really about minimizing
the mean square error. So let's
just do this. Yeah, so it's
about minimizing the mean
squared error. So we know is
that the square is sort of
robust against noise, well use
the accuracy not so accuracy.
So have you have you added noise
to synthetic data and shown
we have our paper I only showed
you here without noise because
one, so the accuracy that is
fundamental understanding. So in
some people, we do have a noisy
data example, the lack of
accuracy will be less as
expected nothing to that. So.
But there are other things we do
not fully understand some. So
the other type of noise would be
if your equation has stochastic
synth driving it that that will
become St. That's an entire
different things that we have
less understanding. We won't
have the very first paper just
recently wrapped up. I'm not
ready to discuss that
extensively yet. We have some
understanding, but we have
struggled with st for quite a
long time. So
okay. You said it early in the
talk. You said, let me see what
you were, you were talking
about. Not having time as part
of the learned. That's and I
thought you meant by that, that
you were simply making the
Markov assumption that you did
not have memory, but then later
you introduced memory. So I
figured that I misunderstood
you. What did you What did you
mean in the early comment? What
was I meant is that which so
which is what's the bet? What I
meant is it for example, if this
is a new one, so let's look this
up my input x and x, so we
should never have t as explicit
info. So for example, I do not
want to measure x as a function
of t I should never have t as a
node in here.
Okay. Yeah. And that's not the
same as making the Markov
assumption that's not that's not
okay it's it's the if you make
market assumption that's true
but it's weaker than that
but they're all Markov right so
anyway, just how
memory is not is not a not
making the Markov assumption
depends on how you find mark
over this one's DeMarco
multistep Markov. So Oh,
I see. Yeah, okay. Yeah. Fine,
but so, yes, well, I think I
think I think I don't that's not
controversial. I just, I
understand now what you're
looking at. Yeah, okay. And I
and go ahead if there's any
others there were definitely
some others down below.
Yeah, well, I want to invite the
Rob Hayes. He asked about the
newest data. But he also, he
also asked on other questions.
So Rob, if you want to unmute
yourself and ask your questions
directly, that would be very
helpful.
So it came down to the look like
the process you're describing
does require each successive
data point to have the same time
step. So you're not folding the
time step in, you're not mapping
it with that. But they do
require sequential time steps to
be equal for all okay, that's
yeah, that's where we have not
worked out. For simpler cases,
we can do variable time
stamping. But for this with
memory, we can't we don't know
how to do that yet. So it is a
requirement at the moment.
Okay. All right. Just Seymour,
are you there? Yes, I am. Yeah.
Okay. Can you ask me a question
directly?
So, I had a question regarding
just a comparison with other
time series forecasting methods.
I was curious if the methods
that you propose, if they are
comparable or better than other
conventional time series
forecasting methods. And if we
have time, I have some other
questions about your other
papers. But it's probably going
to be outside of the scope of
this talk. So
we didn't do comparison with
other tiny. Yeah, there are a
lot of statistical methods to do
that. We didn't do that can
compose? I would guess, look,
this kind of thing is hard to
get without a method. I think, I
don't know I'm not aware of the
method can get this kind of
accuracy with this little data
over this much long time, to be
honest. And if you are aware of
some please let me know I would
be more than interested in
looking into those methods.
Okay. By the way, I didn't I
wasn't aware we didn't do any
comparison. So yeah. Thank you
very much.
All right. Sounds good. phase
out. Are you still there?
Curious in the fastest. All
right, phase out. We heard you.
Can you? Podium up? We barely
hear you. There is? One, I can
just ask. Okay, Faisal asked. In
the fastest slow example, the
GTA and your ln do not diverse
does it imply Lea penal exponent
of zero? Which?
I do not know, to be honest.
Alright. I don't have a good
answer for ya. All right.
Shawn, are you still there? Sean
Smith, from Los Alamos. If you
want to ask a question directly.
Otherwise, I can ask, he asked.
The motivation of this approach
is that to use mathematical
computational tools to
circumvent the necessity for
physical modeling, however,
definition of the state space
that you rely on is a large
proportion of the physical
modeling, even when provided by
experiments. selecting
appropriate instruments requires
insightful physical
understanding. Even when the
state space is only partially
defined using Mori to draw to
Anzick. The selection of the
soft set of the state spaces in
is even more critical. In each
of your examples. The state
space was defined by fiscal
model, do you have any comment
on that convening?
And trying to understand so
question. If I guess is that
about how to select what
variable to in order to
understand the physics, if
that's the case, I think is a
slightly different problem,
right? It's an important
problem. So a question to ask,
even for parser to observe what
variable I want to observe in
order to understand the dynamics
of of the problem. And this, the
method here is just assuming
that's what you observed. So the
limited case that whatever I've
observed something that
completely useless, I see
nothing happens. For example, I
observe. For a moving vehicle, I
observed the vertical location
on vehicle which is zero never
changes. But this message just
said, you've given me that data
and we produce a prediction of
zero, the vertical location
which We'll always be zero. So
which is still correct, but the
use of these results. So I think
these are slightly different
problem, if I understand what
you asked, clear, so, so
identification of the variable
to measure. And this is
important, but a different
equation here is just, if you
observe this, we're going to
produce predictors, which may be
useless if you will observe the
use of these variables. I hope I
understand the question.
Shawn said, Thank you, so. Okay.
Sounds like you answer them
correctly? Well, I don't see any
other question. But I have a
couple of questions, you know,
when you when you extend your
method to the PDE, and you gave
the nice examples, and how, you
know, gave gave us an insight on
how to extend your FM FML
method. You know, so you have
introduced, you know, you can,
you can do so using some linear
map, and but why do you stick
with a linear map, or, you know,
extended to, you know, nonlinear
map, using the neural net? On
spatial? human motivation? Yeah,
exactly. Right. No, no,
we didn't use this, we just that
this thing exists, it's, let's
take this all for less, like,
let's say, it's a worst case, a
new one that can do, we can UNL
would be make everything
nonlinear. So it just motivation
is how we designed the network
structure based on this, because
it's just after no less than a
few 1000 testing cases, and
nothing really worked
consistently. We're just trying
to find ways to see maybe we
need a structure. So we didn't
know what to do. So we look into
all our forward type of thing.
And then we decided, based on
this to design your last
structure mimicking this. Yeah,
exactly. And then you change the
D, you know, differentiation
matrices to nonlinear, right
functions. And by doing so
you're effectively introducing
the space, which is a lot bigger
than just a linear
array, it's bigger than that. So
it can be a nonlinear map. So
in some sense, the training will
be harder than
it will be more expensive,
because we have the block thing.
So input output, forget about
this later, I think that we have
this parallel layers, network
layers here, and then this thing
goes vertically on component
wise So training is, is a little
bit more involved is mostly
because for PE the vector is
much longer. That's actually the
killer part.
Right? So
when I said if I can add in my
finishing slide, when I say most
of our network, simple small,
apply to this, because when we
do PDU, Here, input, one stop.
For this, we use surgical with
one layer of here, because one
layer like that, that luck in
this thing, it works remarkably
well. And in our paper, we
actually did two layers simply
because I told my student look,
if you don't do tell two layers,
people will ask why don't you go
deep network solar? It just one
layer was fine. So the moment it
becomes only that works well.
Okay, well, I was wanting to
ask, you know, there's a sounds
like there's a trade off
between, you know, you're making
the training harder, but in some
sense, you're increasing the
dimension of the parameter
space. So you're hoping that you
will get the better model at the
end? In principle, we
hope that Yeah.
So I guess that's the table.
You're talking about here? Oh,
by the way, the last two slides
examples. You said the PDE with
a missing variable. You look
like a PDE with the missing
equations not variable.
Well, if the entire missing is a
variable, right? This is 2400 v
2500. W, we're missing 25. If
you think the entire video has
5000 thing, we are missing half
of it. So yeah, it's the missing
variable, right.
Insert entire PDE equations with
the first one. You still have a
V and W all of them right?
together. So we're just we don't
have w here is a model of the
only model V only. Okay, this is
only for V. There's nothing you
we only observe the we don't
have W whatsoever.
Oh, got it. Oh, okay. I
misunderstood this like, Oh,
okay. Yeah. All right. Sounds
good. Sounds good. I'm sure
there are more liquid. More
questions. I personally do. But
I think I can ask that.
If you have interested in this,
please feel free to write me
email. I'd be more than happy to
discuss offline. I mean, online
offline to this talk. So I'd be
happy to answer any question.
They said me explore some
possibility to work collaborate
as well. So
that'll be awesome. Yeah. All
right. Thank you so much. Let's,
let's thank our speaker today
and for the wonderful talk, and
as he's done being said,
hopefully there's a future
collaboration between us.
Alright, sounds good. Thank you.
Thank you very much. Thank you
for the invite. Okay, bye bye.